y la exportación de madera de balsa se
disparó en ecuador y las comunidades
indígenas y la amazonía son las que
sufren esa es la principal
hallazgo de la periodista daniela
aguilar en su investigación de la selva
a la china publicada por la historia y
conectas y que ganó el segundo concurso
de periodista por tus derechos y es que
esto se disparó en ecuador ecuador es el
mayor exportador de madera de balsa en
el mundo y pasó de 254 mil metros
cúbicos en 2018 a 574 mil en 2020 china
importa el 66 por ciento de todo lo que
produce este país latinoamericano pero
detrás hay un engaño para las
comunidades indígenas pues mientras los
intermediarios les pagan hasta 22
centavos por cada árbol talado un
exportador les paga a los intermediarios
hasta 150 dólares otro de los programas
premiados fue el de amazonía viva una
serie en el que se reporta un mapa
interactivo con las principales
consecuencias de la amazonía estamos con
diego cazar uno de los periodistas que
hizo parte del equipo diego bienvenido y
como sufre la amazonía según lo que
encontrar
bueno muchas gracias el hallazgo
principal del mapa amazonía viva tiene
que ver con un abandono histórico por
parte del estado ecuatoriano a las
poblaciones ya los recursos naturales de
la amazonía que ahora repercute en una
coyuntura en particular que son dos
decretos emitidos por el gobierno de
guillermo lasso el decreto 95 y el
decreto 191 que propician la explotación
petrolera y la explotación minera en
mayores proporciones esto sin ninguna
consulta previa históricamente no ha
habido consulta previa para los pueblos
amazónicos por parte del estado y esto
es lo que ahora los pueblos amazónicos
reclaman y el mapa amazonía viva lo que
busca es servir de instrumento a las
comunidades amazónicas para que puedan
denunciar en tiempo real las
afectaciones que viven frente al
extractivismo
gracias diego y sigan ustedes con
nosotros